[Music]
what up guys
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about whatever we want
and today's segment is ask an expert and
we got
don who is a former marine raider which
is special
operations of the military and if you
guys got a question
i do okay how many um
missions have you done
can you you know oh man i don't know
okay so like
when you're in regular military right
like when you get
when you're when you get deployed like
you go to like
iraq or afghanistan or one of the
countries that
we're in but i know like special ops
people
can be in any place like south america
or whatever right
did you do that worldwide stuff like all
over the world
um in special operations you do my last
appointment was over to the philippines
wow we're in there yeah it's like uh
al-qaeda is there right
isis isis is there are they philippines
yeah what are they doing over there i
think it's okay
are you sure yeah okay yeah we're good
why is isis in the philippines um
so the southern islands of the
philippines
it's called mindanao and all the small
little islands
um they've always been controlled by um
a lot of terrorist organizations like
the abu sayyaf uh
the milf the myth they're called the
milf
the milk they call them the milfs the
biff and other terrorist organizations
down there and
for the longest they've just been doing
like uh kidnapped for ransom
operations piracy operations and they're
all like
middle eastern terrorist organizations
or filipino they're filipino terrorists
filipino and then a lot of influence
from uh like the acapella of malaysia
indonesia
kind of muslim influence over there
because pretty much the majority of the
religion down in the southern islands
are
muslim and then of course like the most
filipinos we know in america are
catholics right but um yeah they have a
lot of influence from there but
because of that i think that there was a
huge influence and some people
came over there and was trying to like
start up so like
isis so wherever there's a muslim
population
does isis try to go and infiltrate
and bring extremism there um
because i'm assuming like when i was in
malaysia there's like muslims obviously
but they're just like
they're not extremists yeah violent ones
but like yeah so
i'm wondering is that how they kind of
go into these different countries
i would say the religion is a portion of
it but also the destabilization of a
specific area
just like down there like in the very
far corners of it it's hard for the
filipino
uh military to kind of have a lot of
influence on right because a lot of
support needs to
get out there and all the missions so
it's like the wild west
like it's like it is a part of the
philippines but it's so hard for them to
control that
area yeah but they also have intense
recruitment like isis anyway like
um they use a lot of social media and
[ __ ] that's true yeah
it's pretty pretty weird yeah but when
we were in the philippines uh this city
called morale got taken over
by isis so we were able to help them get
that back
but it was completely what does that
look like like are they like trucks in
the streets and like
yeah we're the new leader do they
announce we're not there
for like we're not running and gunning
with the filipinos but we're there to
advise and assist
and help them with their with their
mission over there we're in civilian
clothes we're in civilian clothes
yeah are they are you there as military
or you're just there as like
a journalist or um i don't
we're i mean we're there for the
military you know but like the the
people that are there how do they see
you do they see you as like
um like like double 07 like you're
pretending
oh okay it was we were wearing uh
civilian clothes
probably to not get seen by news
reporters and things like that yeah um
as well as
uh not look any different than um the
locals
pretty much so we're helping
like you the way that you guys were
helping was like advising
so you go to these different countries
that need help and support
to battle terrorism or whatever and then
you're like all right so
we dealt with them before this is how
you help how you get them
exactly um and that's the one of the
biggest missions of special operations
forces to go over
and train other militaries to help them
fight their own wars or create one right
do you guys ever
fight alongside with them yes
um it just depends on the area of um
armed conflict that we're in so like in
iraq and afghanistan we're fighting with
them
um and then the philippines were
fighting through them so like they're
leading the charge um it just depends on
the area in some parts of africa
we're fighting with them it just depends
do you help train
the local population or their police or
or their military
it's always different right like in
afghanistan my team was helping the
local militia that we were building but
another team was fighting with their
commandos
and then it just depends on the area did
you have uh were you worried about
you know you could be working with
militia who also
maybe have like a terrorist inserted
with them
yeah that happens all the time so um
like a double agent
yeah like in afghanistan we had um the
team i replaced that had three guys
killed
from one of the guys they were training
um another team so that guy was
undercover the whole time
yeah so he's like in the green zone with
you guys and then he turns on you guys
then he turned
on how did he was he was it like
training no he ran into the office
um and then shot everybody in our
commands oh
shoot that's crazy yeah and then prime
my
business partner yeah he was um walking
outside of his command center
and um an afghan national army special
forces guys that they were training
just flips an rpg rocket and started
shooting at the
command center shot eight rockets at
prime what
eight rockets because he was he was a
insurgent he was like a
he was like isis or whatever i don't
know the full story because they ended
up
killing that guy they don't know if he
was i mean even if he was they probably
wouldn't
say because they don't want to say like
their ranks are infiltrated by
isis or i mean it was a taliban at that
moment so they would never
admit to it they wouldn't admit to it
yeah but they also had some grievances
with the guy
um is it ever personal because could it
be like they're not a terrorist but then
they're just messed up
yeah so that's why i remember that story
i told you about that
guy beating up our dog yeah so that was
like a scenario like that
um uh this guy and
he was one of the ana sf so army
national
army or afghan national army special
forces guys that we were
training and going fighting with um
like one of his bosses or one of my
bosses told his bosses to tell him
something
and he did and he got extremely mad at
us and it was like something
super petty like hey make sure we check
that security or check that building the
right way but he felt it as completely
disrespect that
my commander had to tell his commander
to tell him so instead of talking
directly to him yeah so he felt like he
looked extremely bad
and his friends said something about it
like made fun of him
really lightly about it like oh yeah go
listen to the american or something like
that
and because of that it was like it
developed for like three weeks
and he was like super angry at us and he
ended up beating up
one of our dogs that we had to put down
like a like a police dog
no i was one of the dogs that we picked
up like a like a pet like a pet i see
yeah so to take it out he took it out on
a dog yeah he beat the [ __ ] out of that
dog oh
yeah so we were like felt threatened
like wow the [ __ ] would we do that so we
had to kick him off
so he he stopped being trained by you
guys
yeah well like when it happened we're
like what the [ __ ] is going on did
anyone on your team
beat his ass or no no okay
got it i got it there's a very special
forces answer yeah
uh but that that like definitely adds
conflict to the relationship right
because it's like our country we're
trying to work together
yeah but if the people aren't working it
out or there's just
it's like how do you solve this you know
you don't want the small problems
to affect the bigger problem you guys
know and that's why like
when people are at home in america here
and they always like are like oh why are
we over there and all that stuff but
the situation is so complex everywhere
that american forces are whether it's
like fighting for america
fighting helping that country or
whatever the case is is just so complex
and
we really don't know the full situation
unless we're on the ground
trying to help out and even as a
military guy now like other missions
going around the world like
i don't really know what the dynamics
are like i can't really judge them for
why they're there what mission set they
have you know it's
hard to say so for you you only know
like when it's your turn
and you're there for that moment but it
can change
yeah and most of the time in the
military it's everything's
compartmentalized
right so it's on like a need to know
basis right unless you you need to know
i mean if you need to know they'll tell
you if not then they'd
just do your work yeah they really don't
spread that too much
out you guys are dealing with a lot of
cash and stuff sometimes
like like you know you know some [ __ ]
happens
would you have any theories about that
like the missing billions and all that
stuff over
over in those countries no i have no
idea what you're talking about
you don't mean like um uh i'm just
kidding um no
but when we were in uh afghanistan we
had a partner
force with us for a little bit they were
from the uae
these guys were like all the gucci gear
because they had so much money but they
would bring like
i remember like black trash bags of like
us hundreds to build a mosque or
something in one of the villages
it was insane so they're from the
emirates united arab emirates so
their soldiers are like rich soldiers
i'm sure it was like government's money
boots and
no like all the gucci cool tactical like
expensive expensive
really expensive stuff expensive gear
yeah yeah
and then so you're like how do you guys
have this
kind of money but it's because their
government's really rich yeah oh
damn and they they don't they don't have
a big military like we do
you know so like each guy probably gets
a lot more allotted to him
for his training or whatever the case
and they just hand out a huge
trash bag i remember the trash bags of
like
hundreds and fifties or whatever it was
some of it was afghan money some of it
was
you know us dollars to build the mosque
out there right because i think their
one of their main mission was to
spread the right islam um different
ones right like sunni shia
that's different tribes in iraq um
i think they were trying to push the
right form of religion out there because
i mean everybody's muslim but
christianity catholicism to different
mormons
you know or it's all different so
they're trying to spread the right
religion to have good religion i see how
do you guys track all that [ __ ] like
they got trash bags of cash for that and
then you guys
anything with their money or anything
like that but we also have
operational funds to help build um
projects like that if they need a
hospital or a school or help them do
that but we really try to
have them try to fund it through their
own government because
i mean like in kabul they have money you
know like the country has some type of
money so
we try to push it down from up there so
that they can they can get the money
through their own system because we're
not gonna be there forever
do you ever go can i take out the trash
for you guys
yeah i mean we talked about it but are
there countries where you're like
i'm not even supposed to say that i was
there and then in like
you did missions and you did great but
you can't get a medal or be recognized
like or any of that stuff
um i think philippines was that for a
little bit in the beginning
so we're not supposed to be known that
we're there
i mean yeah because the political
sensitivity at the time was extremely
difficult as probably is now as well
because
uh the president duterte he did not like
u.s troops whatsoever and
i'm pretty sure they just kicked all
americans out like
wait so if he says something pretty
[ __ ] crazy the president didn't want
you guys
was he didn't he had to know that you
guys were there helping
but dude he knew so he was just saying
it like
[ __ ] americans but then he was like but
i need your guys's help it's all it's
all politics
yeah yeah and i'm sure he had his own
agendas i don't really know like what
they were but yeah you know politics
yeah
they'll say one thing for the country
but yeah they haven't you ever like see
[ __ ] on the news
where a journalist is telling a story
and then like but you know what really
happened like
oh in afghanistan it happened a few
times like it was like a new york times
story i won't get into it too much but
like there was like a lot of times that
people report stuff that was not
that's not how it went down how do you
guys feel about stuff like that
don't you go like that's not right you
get it right you liar yeah i mean like
you want to say something but i mean
you say something then they're going to
try to interview you or whatever the
case is
so tough do you ever see anything sick
like [ __ ] ufos or some [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah actually yeah really yeah would you
say you can't talk about that one
that'd be tight it happened to his dmt
trip
probably yeah i haven't seen anything
like that though
or area 51 stuff or anything did any
mission or country blow your mind to
where you got there you're like
i don't think i'd ever be in this place
in my life
if it wasn't for the military oh all of
them all of them well except for the
philippines i'll grow the philippines oh
sometimes yeah what a place had the best
food out of all the countries you've
been to
like local food oh man
they all have their own or was dishes
that was really like [ __ ]
they're any like locals like man you
guys are not amazing oh dude
in afghanistan one time we had like a
goat
they [ __ ] slit a throat and they
threw it on like they skinned it and
threw on the fire for probably like 30
minutes
oh my god so it was kind of raw it was
[ __ ] so raw
and they were they gave it to you like
you don't want to disrespect them
yeah they put like heaviest amounts of
salt on there like was it good
no it was not good but you had to act
like it's good it was gold sashimi
yeah pretty much dude it was pretty to
keep up relations so you have to be like
yeah
yeah exactly oh but in the philippines
um
the filipino marines down there the
special operations guy they went out to
one of the islands and they killed the
wild boar for us and they came back and
they made wild boar
adobo wow holy [ __ ] it was so
[ __ ] good dude that's like one of the
best adobe ever
best for sure dude oh my god so good and
then they also had
like this like this version of a crab
it's like a two-headed crab
what um it's like one on top of it like
other i don't know it's kind of weird
but they cooked it in um
sprite the crab it's [ __ ] bomb too
oh [ __ ] yeah this episode of off the
record is brought to you by
hbo max hbo max is a streaming platform
that bundles all of hbo together and
has some of the most iconic movies tv
shows
like friends fresh prince of bel air
and it's all together in the same place
yo you know what i'm about to do this
romantic season what
all right so you know we all want to hbo
and chill with somebody that we care
about right but we also have to be
responsible during this time because we
might have a long distance lover or
something like that true
so hey your honey is far away this is
what you can do
why don't you sign up and you can
respectively
in your own beds chill and watch
simultaneously together yeah and share
some of your favorite shows with each
other
yup and then so on one side you are
listening to each other breathe
and talk about the film while you're
watching it
in your own home respectfully during
this time sounds very romantic but safe
yes so a show that means you just
finished watching is euphoria have you
seen it
no it's about this high schooler and uh
her and all her friends are drug addicts
so it kind of reminded
so it's very relatable and like this
crazy adventure that you get to go under
of like her dealing with like her mental
health and all the crazy stuff that's
happening it's a really really good show
and we're
glued to it and it was cool that we have
hbo max so we can watch it every single
night and binge
but you guys should set up different
beds in different rooms and then
sleep separately like that and you can
watch
online together and still hear each
other because that's more that's a
millennial
love right there that's true right now
new and returning subscribers
can sign up and for this limited time
prepay and save offer
to receive 20 when pre-paying the first
six months of a hbo max
subscription offer ends march 1st
2021 and restrictions do apply baby
hbo max has something for everyone every
day check out the link in the
description and get 20
off of the first prepaid six months of
your hbo max subscription
so you know like you're eating all these
different foods right like you ever get
the runs during a mission oh dude and
then like you're crapping yourself and
you've got a stomachache and you need
pepto but you got a mission to do like
i've [ __ ] myself so many times you just
[ __ ] in yourself and just let it go
yeah that first iraq appointment i had
ate some bad chicken
that um i put in the microwave but it
was breaded
so we they airdropped us all our food so
i didn't know if it was like cooked
it was supposed to be cooked like fried
but i we just threw it in the microwave
and i ate i was eating it on the way out
and
i was like a six day mission six days
yeah and i literally had
i was in the turret too literally pull
off rip off my uh flight suit
and then poop out of the side off the
side of the truck
like blasted it is the truck moving
yeah holy [ __ ] yeah it was bad dude i
had to clean it with like a little
toothbrush okay
you can't have it roll over real quick
nah they didn't want to pull over dude i
thought it was messing around
in the philippines i got sick i had
dysentery in the philippines from eating
all that
crazy [ __ ] all the time what's this
interior i thought that was like some
organ trail disease
it is yeah it's just like extreme
diarrhea
and bacteria in your gut damn
i can just throw it up and and diarrhea
so when you're like in the
middle of a mission and like you're like
doing some spy [ __ ] right and then you
feel your stomach going
you're like if you had if you had some
stomach issues you probably shouldn't go
on the mission because you're just
telling you're like top officer like
dude i got the runs yeah you should
because
it's that normal though cuz won't they
be like that's [ __ ] [ __ ] dude yeah
you're not gonna do this
if you have to [ __ ] people will smell
that if you're supposed to be in a hide
site or something
damn you know what i mean so yeah dude
imagine missing the bin laden ring
because you had the [ __ ]
i know right it is you can't even get i
would probably suck it up for that one
right yeah damn that's [ __ ] crazy did
you ever think
oh my god because you were in an 09 you
said are you
um did you ever think we're going to i'm
going to get bin laden this is the
mission we're going to get bill no i
knew that
our unit was not going to get bin laden
yeah that's like what tier 1 unit [ __ ]
yeah exactly have you seen that um
rob what's his name he's like a
reservist marine
lieutenant rob riggles rob riggles he
made a little skit on
um him shooting bin laden oh you guys
gotta watch it check it out
it's pretty funny so like the tier one
guys when they walk by the tier two guys
and tier two as well by the two they're
like
[ __ ] little [ __ ] and they do that
probably not the cat guys and probably
not the
delta force guys but the seal team six
guys yeah
probably those guys all have like crazy
beards i always see those guys with
beards
um probably it depends on their mission
set right so if they have to go [ __ ]
clean shaven to like a country in asia
or something like that they probably
wouldn't look
normal with a full beard but like in the
middle east like in afghanistan
um we all grew beards because
the level of respect that you got when
you're speaking with a beard is
completely different
why because they see you as a man i see
you as a man yeah
i couldn't grow a really good beard
though it's pretty gross
so but if you have a facial hair they're
like facial hair then you're good
oh damn yeah i think my friend did a
mission trip in
afghanistan or or one of the countries
and he was like made fun of
because he didn't have facial hair yeah
they make fun of you yeah they look down
on you like you're a kid
and [ __ ] yeah well think about how easy
those guys grow here man yeah yeah
like [ __ ] nadeem grows hair up to
here
[Laughter]
damn that's crazy so like it it seems
like you had a really
exciting military career like if you're
built for this
kind of crazy intense lifestyle what
made you want to
finish it early because you're still a
young dude man like
yeah yeah some of these guys go until
they're like 50 right
um i mean they do normally 20 and then
yeah i mean it just depends on their job
and how well their body holds up
um but it permits they might go to the
full 30.
yeah but like special op guys are how
old usually
in the 30s really yeah so that's the
prime
and then they're done yeah and they're
like they'll rotate out and do like some
uh staff job or something like that
let's stay with their meeting and
instructors it takes a minute so like to
get in you you
usually have like one enlistment in
right because yeah for the marine corps
you
have to have some time in the regular
marine corps before you can go to
special operations so your career is
actually
really short it's like less than 10
years
no i did 12 years active and then you're
in the reserves oh i mean like as a
special op
you sign a contract for five years after
you graduate school-ish
um i think that's what it is now but it
always changes but you
you owe us a lot of time because they
just spent like a million bucks to train
you or whatever it is i don't know how
much it is but so let's say your
contract is five years
can you do it again if you wanted to and
go i want another five
kind of like but then you would probably
rotate out um so like
i got out but my next position would
have been an instructor in north
carolina
so you wouldn't be out in the country
yeah
yeah do you ever paint a target paint a
target yeah you know
you know how sick that sounds yeah i
painted a lot of targets yeah yeah
yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah so so was your
contract up and you're just like i'm not
gonna resign up
i'm just ready to go on the fence like
hey what do i want to do with my life
and um i didn't want to start a family
in the military
because i just see a lot of families
just like divorces
yeah and it's especially special
operations yeah cause you're gone
a lot you're just never home she's never
home
yeah so so so um for you you were like
at the five-year mark you that's when
you decided that you're done with the
military
i was at uh 11 and a half and i was like
hey i think it's time for me to rotate
out or
do something else in my life yeah what
would i what would you
need what would you have needed to
happen for you to finish the 20
like what would you think would it need
to be on the table for you to go like
you know what i can keep doing this is
it would you like out of special
operations
no i was saying it for sure i would i
wouldn't leave special operations
um i don't know man
was your commander like you're the
[ __ ] best to have i hate to lose you
no he was like [ __ ] yeah finally getting
out dude no i'm just kidding but no
um i don't know man i think that was the
right time for me to get out i wanted
and i learned a lot from the military
you know i learned so much about
discipline really made me into the man
i am kind of today and taught me
accountability which is huge
self-accountability and the people
around me but
i wanted to learn other things and i
also wanted to have a better future for
myself and my family and deploying going
back and forth
you can't really have like the most set
up future for your family so if you were
a special ops
dude you're you you realize like oh this
lifestyle i can't have like
a wife and kids and be be both you can a
lot of guys do and a lot of guys are
happy but also the other half is or like
60
of it is like it's a struggle to kind of
fight that
you ever watched that show called seal
team i have not it's pretty good and
that looks like [ __ ] but
but that's what that show's about i
guess oh yeah about like the family
livestream yeah
any has there ever been a time where
like a black suv rolls up to your house
and two guys in suits come out and
you're like god i know they want me back
you're like i'm retired we need you
you're the best
you're the best that we had the target
painter we ever had in the whole thing
you were like no i'm done i'm retired
yeah
no definitely not that'd be cool though
oh those are all that's so funny
you ever throw a grenade i know have you
ever walked away from an explosion
yes and you didn't even see it yeah yes
oh you going like this though
no you have earplugs why didn't you look
at it
because it's not cool dude exactly dude
don't you can't do it yeah that's tight
[Music]
foreign